foreign
[Music]
of being successful is just showing up
welcome to the day in the life of Samuel
Leeds so I spent a lot of time buying
houses traveling around looking at my
portfolio managing the projects but I
also spent a lot of time training other
people how to get into property too this
month I'm on tour I've been to
Manchester Birmingham I'm now here in
London we've got a packed out room with
over 400 people and this is the property
investors crash course as soon as it
finishes I got a party tonight which is
going to be a lot of fun so welcome to
the day in the life up
true sometimes people might say I've got
20 and I don't need anything I just got
20.
there we go
so we're here with 400 people in London
and I've just told everybody to write
down and share why they're here what
they're wanting to learn today and then
when I'm gonna get a feel for the room
and then just gonna decide what to teach
all of these days are kind of freestyled
I'm going to be finding live deals on
stage and they're just bouncing off of
everybody so it's gonna be fun
[Music]
all the things inside here that's
comfortable right all this stuff's
comfortable
where do you think the money is do you
think it's inside or outside of your
comfort zone outside thank you so the
money's here
so we're on a quick break and I'm just
like preparing right now what I'm gonna
do next because every time I run a one
pound crash course the content's always
different because they want different
things people ask and ask different
questions or the vibe is different the
thing is I want to make sure even though
they just paid one pound to be here I
want to act like they paid a million
pounds I want to give them so much value
and content because people some of these
guys have traveled in from all over the
world so I want to make this good
[Music]
the reason that people at my courses
don't get bored is because they're not
just learning but they're actually doing
so right now everyone's been set the
challenge of finding a live property
investment deal and I'm going to get
some of the best people to come and
Pitch their deal from the stage and the
best deal I'm gonna give the team 300
pound cash prize to to see what happens
so if there's someone that's got
something and they've prepared a little
pitch where you are you've got a banger
you've got always what you want to share
oh I think this has got huge potential
though what are you guys thinking
then we're gonna give a cash prize of
300 pounds for the winning team
now if you thought that the hotel was a
better opportunity on the beach then
please share now
60 70 80 90 100 that is 100 pounds for
you sir patience give them a hand
[Applause]
good
so the course is just finished it's been
absolutely amazing I'm buzzing I'm
excited however we've now got a party
that's going to be starting in one hour
so the guys are turning around the room
I'm gonna go and get changed ready for
the party tonight
[Music]
the academy has been a life-changing
opportunity for me like it's not only
change my life it changed my family's
life it's changed my brother's life
now that I'm in the academy I'm kind of
open to more creative you know property
investment
I exited a business where I was stressed
out I was burnt out all the time and now
I'm managing assets which are making me
about 15 grand profit equals let's do it
again
let's do it again
all my life has changed massively now I
can spend more time with my family which
I love let's do it again
[Music]
be able to actually build an academy
actually get all of these events which
is so well worth it
[Music]
oh the community is very warm very
friendly very helpful
this evening's great like you can't be
been surrounded by people that are
willing to be invest in themselves
the fact that people are actually in the
network themselves they've all got so
much value to bring in so much knowledge
that when you put these kind of people
together they can't help but be
successful in this manner this is a
pleasure in one space it's amazing
I always like to bring the fire
especially if it's my birthday party or
something like that so in a moment I'm
going to be introducing you to an
incredible rap Duo they broke Guinness
Book of Records by the amount of charts
that they sold so could we please make
some noise for the one and only crept
and Conan
tell them don't waste my time
pray to the Lord Nick in this cold world
I'm a Born Sinner be poor liquor
[Music]
my phone
no no
no where else man where else can you
experience something like this where
else can you see Krypton Conan give this
book a record breaking rap Duo
performing chatting to Jordan Haynes TV
star walking around with
multi-millionaires doing business where
else nowhere just at the Samuel Leeds
Academy celebrating life you're in
business it's been a good day I hope you
enjoyed it I'll see you next time
[Music]
no no no no